[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal
menschen auf der flucht frauen die sich
von ihren kindern verabschiedet haben
kinder von ihren vätern ohne zu wissen
ob man sich je wieder sehen wird
und die die bleiben suchen bei luftalarm
schutz in kellern und buckeln
bilder die bei der alten generation auch
hierzulande schlimmste erinnerungen
wachrufen an eine zeit von der mann
dachte sie sei in europa überwunden
guten abend zum heute journal am
sechsten tag dieses krieges von dem wir
nicht wissen wann wir aufhören werden
die tage noch einzeln zu zählen heute
war das zu beobachten was viele
befürchtet hatten dass die russischen
angriffe massiver werden brutaler
zerstörerischer tödlicher ralf panik
gibt einen überblick über die aktuellen
geschehnisse in der ukraine
helfer tragen einen schwer verletzten
menschen aus den trümmern überall um sie
herum zerstörung es ist das
verwaltungsgebäude im zentrum der stadt
haag im osten der ukraine zweitgrößte
stadt des landes geschossen von
russischen raketen am frühen morgen
gegen 8 uhr ortszeit
[Musik]
auch wohnhäuser in der umgebung wurden
bombardiert und haben nicht nur
zerstörung angerichtet nach angaben
ukrainischer rettungskräfte sollen
allein in haag heute mindestens zehn
menschen getötet dutzende verletzt
worden sein
es ist terror gegen die stadt gegen die
ukraine es gab kein militärisches ziel
auf dem platz sowie in den wohnvierteln
die rakete dem platz getroffen hat ist
offener unverhüllte thermo
der russische verteidigungsminister
widerspricht und kündigt an die angriffe
fortzusetzen bis alle ziele erreicht
sind
die russische armee besetzt das
ukrainische territorium nicht sie
ergreift alle maßnahmen um das leben und
die sicherheit von zivilisten zu
schützen
und ich möchte betonen dass nur
militärische ziele mit präzisionswaffen
angegriffen werden
bereits seit tagen wächst der
militärische druck aus vielen teilen des
landes werden gefechte und
bombenangriffe gemeldet und dass
russische truppen vorrückten
nach carson etwa im süden der ukraine
auch hier russischer beschuss
und es sind eben nicht nur militärische
ziele die getroffen werden auch dringend
mittlerweile russische soldaten in die
stadt ein doch sie treffen nicht nur auf
militärischen widerstand
gegen die vorwärts drängenden truppen
wehren sich zivilisten wie hier in der
südukrainischen stadt milito pohl
versuchen unbewaffnet mit friedlichen
mitteln den vormarsch irgendwie
aufzuhalten und sei es nur für kurze
momente
auch rund um die hauptstadt kiew wächst
der druck am morgen tauchten
satellitenbilder auf die einen mehr als
65 kilometer langen russischen
militärkonvoi zeigen mittlerweile soll
dieser etwa 25 kilometer verkehr stehen
er kommt aber nur langsam voran dennoch
ein bedrohliches vorzeichen am abend
weitere anzeichen dass ein russischer
großangriff auf die ukrainische
hauptstadt bevorsteht russische raketen
treffen den fernsehturm im zentrum der
stadt der turm wurde nur zum teil
beschädigt aber wichtige kommunikations
möglichkeiten wurden zerstört fernseher
radio programme können nicht mehr senden
fünf menschen sollen gestorben sein so
der hierfür bürgermeister vitali
klitschko der sich mehrfach am tag in
videobotschaften an die ukraine am ende
die lage ist bedrohlich
der feind will das herz unseres landes
erobern wir aber werden kämpfen kiew
nicht aufgeben streitkräfte verteidigung
bürger sind bereit wir werden unsere
hauptstadt verteidigen
vor den toren der stadt hamm ukrainische
reservisten und freiwillige
straßensperren errichtet kontrollpunkte
währenddessen aber versuchen viele die
noch in der stadt sind irgendwie zu
fliehen versuchen den drohnen kämpfen
und kiew zu entkommen
general ade ihres vaters uns
zugeschaltet ehemaliger brigadegeneral
der bundeswehr und militär politischer
berater im bundeskanzleramt guten abend
herr
frost versuchen gemeinsam so etwas zu
verstehen wie sich die militärische
situation dort jetzt entwickelt gerade
auch mit blick erstmal auf diesen wert
auch für laien sehr eindrücklichen
konvoi in die russen der richtung kiel
schicken der 60 kilometer oder noch
länger sein soll was für schlüsse ziehen
sie aus solchen bildern und
informationen von von so einem konvoi
naja die kräfte die jetzt im raum sind
waren die kräfte der ersten staffel die
russen gehen jetzt mit den haupt kräften
der zweiten staffel weiter vor das ist
eindrucksvoll auf den bildern zu sehen
und es geht ihnen jetzt darum kiew zu
nehmen also zumindest so zu belagern
auszutrocknen dass da kein widerstand
mehr kommen kann aber sie müssen auch
mit spezialkräften rein weil in kiew ja
die politische leitung des landes ist
auch die militärische leitung es geht um
die führung letztlich des gesamten
ukrainischen widerstandes und die läuft
aus kiew deswegen ist von strategischer
bedeutung deswegen diese massive militär
konzentration gerade bei kiew es heißt
dass an diesem konvoi auch panzer zu
sehen sind und schweres
artilleriegeschütz was jetzt eigentlich
nicht für irgendwelche kleineren oder
präzisere schläge gedacht dass das
massiv zerstört also geht man mit sowas
in eine großstadt rein
ja ich glaube sie werden nicht wahllos
in die stadt schießen aber es ist
natürlich das problem bei den
sogenannten urban warfare also bei
kämpfen im urbanen umfeld
das zivilbevölkerung immer in
mitleidenschaft gezogen wird das kann
man fast gar nicht ausschließen der
verteidiger nutzt das natürlich auch die
wie die infrastruktur und kann sich da
auch sehr gut aufstellen und der
angreifer das sind jetzt die russen die
müssen halt sehen wie sie die stadt
freikämpfen um letztlich auch die die
leitzentralen des landes zu
neutralisieren das ist eine schwierige
sache man kommt schnell in die städte
rein also man die amerikaner haben das
ja in bagdad gesehen aber danach dort zu
bleiben das nachhaltig zu besetzen ist
ein ganz schwieriger job könnte man so
ein konto wenn ich eigentlich auch
angreifen ich mein der zieht sich da vor
aller augen kilometer lang durch die
gegend frage ich mich als laie ob man
die nicht aus der luft beschießen kann
die ukraine haben ja auch noch flugzeuge
oder naja ich glaube die sind weitgehend
neutralisiert die russen haben ja in den
ersten tagen mit ihren luftstreitkräften
auch mit ihren raketen die flugplätze
zerstört und die luftabwehr
neutralisiert der ukraine da ist nicht
mehr viel was die ukraine da
entgegensetzen können denn dann könnten
sie in der tat diese kolonnen angreifen
aber die russen haben augenscheinlich
die luft herrschaft ich denke davon muss
man ausgehen
deswegen haben sie da letztlich nicht zu
befürchten
was können denn die ukraine jetzt
überhaupt noch was kann die armee jetzt
noch tun um kiew zu halten oder ist das
ja ich muss so rasch zu glauben man
könnte kiew halten ja das ist frost ganz
schwieriges thema die kampfmoral der
ukraine ist groß sie ist bewundernswert
aber die russische militärmaschine ist
ja massiv überlegen in allen haut
waffensystemen und auch der angriff im
land man muss auch in den süden gehen
nicht also sie die russen greifen aus
der krise heraus jetzt richtung usa an
ich denke die stadt wird auch in kürze
genommen werden und sie sind auf der
anderen seite des asowschen meeres eben
auch im vormarsch richtung dombach mario
pohl waren die kämpfe aber das ist jetzt
auch mehr oder weniger in russischer
hand und die landbrücke zwischen kremmen
und das ist auch geschlossen mehr oder
weniger die russen versuchen auch in der
west ukraine die den nachschub an waffen
und munition für die ukraine aus polen
heraus
letztlich abzuriegeln
inwieweit das erfolgreich ist muss man
sehen also die ukraine haben eigentlich
eher als rein militärisch betrachtet nur
die chance in einem die russen in einen
andauernden konflikt zu ziehen in einen
abnutzungskrieg und auf zeit zu spielen
dazu müssen sie letztlich guerilla
taktisch vorgehen und das ist das was
putin weiß gott nicht will das ist seine
größte angst jetzt eigentlich in einen
langen abnutzungskrieg hineinzugeraten
mit den ukrainern die ja für viele
russen auch ein bruder volk ist das ist
kann er sich nicht leisten das ist ein
interessanter aspekt sowieso niemand man
sieht viel diese bilder die ukraine
zivilisten auch alte frauen männer quer
beet sich diesen soldaten diesen russen
die sind natürlich sprachlich alle die
können sich ja bestens verständigen die
ukraine und die russen in sich
entgegenstellen und sagen haut aus
unserem land ab oder anfang ukrainische
lieder zu singen und man hat zu den
eindruck dass diese russischen soldaten
auch dahin gar nicht wissen wie sie
damit umgehen sollen ich meine krieg ist
auch psychologisch und psyche war die
wirkt so etwas auf soldaten wenn sie
merken die sie in der die bevölkerung so
entgegen stellen eine bevölkerung die
ihnen eigentlich kulturell sehr nahe
ja das ist mit sicherheit für viele
russische soldaten vor allen dingen die
die unmittelbar lässt sich an der front
sind ein problem das kann man sehr gut
nachvollziehen es gibt ja tausende von
verwandtschaftlichen beziehungen auch
zwischen ukrainer und russen es gibt ja
auch sehr viele ethnische russen in der
ukraine
deswegen kann sich putin einen lang
andauernden konflikt in der ukraine der
blutig ist der die zivilbevölkerung mit
einzieht kann er sich eigentlich nicht
leisten da ist jeder tag ein tag zu viel
für ihn der westen schaut bei all dem zu
also jedenfalls militärisch greift die
nato nicht ein
es gibt aber diese forderung nach
flugverbotszonen was würde beim prinzip
bedeuten die nato beginnt einen direkten
krieg mit russland eine atommacht
naja flugverbotszonen das haben wir ja
angewandt also im irak auch auf dem
balkan auch in libyen also das
funktioniert eigentlich nur mit einer
sehr stark militärisch überlegenen macht
gegenüber einem mehr oder weniger
militärischen habe nichts der so ein
bisschen luftstreitkräfte noch hat oder
hubschrauber da kann man sowas
etablieren wenn die nato das machen
würde dann wäre sie faktisch im krieg
mit russland die russen werden das
niemals zulassen
und das ist ein vorschlag der ein no go
ist letztlich für die nato und der
nato-generalsekretär ist ja gerade in
polen er hat auch die polen so ein
bisschen das polnische militär
zurückgepfiffen
auch diese idee der ukraine mit
kampfpiloten aus der polen
herauszuhelfen in dem konflikt da hat er
eindeutig ein riegel vorgeschoben weil
er partout nicht will und das ist
konsens auch in der nato dass die nato
als solches kriegspartei wird aber man
muss auch sehen durch unsere
waffenlieferungen sind wir faktisch
dabei in diese richtung und zu bewegen
und ich dass wir und wenn der krieg
länger dauern sollte der ukrainische
widerstand weitergeht dann kann das sehr
schnell in einen stellvertreterkrieg
münden und dann kann sich auch schnell
die sache in richtung auf eine
kriegspartei entwickeln das ist so ein
risiko und das kann man muss man
politisch sehr sehr gut steuern
damit man nicht in diese richtung
marschiert eine gefährliche situation
hatte ich danken für das gespräch
vielen dank fürs morgen war
und dann schalten wir noch direkt live
in die ukraine zu unserer reporterin
katrin eigendorf kathrin ist den himmel
mit ski das ist im westen der ukraine
südwestlich von kiew katrin schilder uns
doch einfach deine eindrücke heute
also aktuell ist es so dass auch hier
seit einer halben stunde eigentlich
permanent fliegeralarm ist und wir
eigentlich jetzt bald auch in den keller
gehen müssen also auch hier wo im
prinzip noch nicht aktiv kämpfe
stattfinden wird die situation zunehmend
angespannter was wir sehen an diesem tag
6 des krieges ist dass klar wird putin
wird ganz gezielt die zivilbevölkerung
angreifen und das merken natürlich die
ukraine auch nach einer welle der
solidarität
und der entschlossenheit gegen diese
militärische übermacht russland
anzukämpfen ja dieser krieg hat ja nicht
nur auf dem boden sondern sehr sehr viel
auch im internet stattgefunden hat sich
das jetzt ein bisschen gekehrt dass die
leute jetzt sehen was sind die opfer die
hier gebracht werden müssen und der
experte hat es ja vorher schon schon
erklärt wieso ein krieg ablauf läuft im
prinzip wird ein teil der
zivilbevölkerung hier einfach opfer
dieses krieges in dem sie sich als
schutzschilde vor panzer stellen indem
sie in wohnhäusern bleiben die dann
bombardiert werden es sind ja auch
gezielt zentren von städten in hf
angegriffen wurden und darauf richtet
sich im prinzip jetzt auch die
hauptstadt kiew ein ich glaube putin in
diesem jetzigen augenblick kennt keine
grenzen was sein angriff auf das
ukrainische volk angeht und darauf
stellen sich die ukraine ein und sie
erleben natürlich auch mittlerweile wie
menschen sterben sie sehen dass ihre
väter brüder in situationen ziehen die
wirklich wahnsinnig gefährlich sind und
jeden tag sterben mehr menschen
danke katrin für die eindrücke und für
die arbeit wieder für uns vor ort machst
ja und der westen der steht daneben
liefert waffen gibt geld versichert
seine solidarität verhängt sanktionen
betreibt krisendiplomatie und muss am
ende doch entsetzt zu sehen wie ein
worst case nach dem anderen eintritt
während die ukrainische regierung weiter
verzweifelt um hilfe ruft das ganze
drama dieses dilemmas wurde besonders
sichtbar als präsident des elends die
heute per video vor dem europäischen
parlament auftrat kam felix jochens
berichtet
demonstrative solidarität bei der
sondersitzung des eu parlaments blau und
gelb dominiert den saal es sind die
farben seines landes
in einer emotionalen videoansprache
bittet der ukrainische präsident erneut
um den eben beitritt
unser volk ist sehr motiviert wirklich
sehr wir kämpfen für unsere rechte für
unsere freiheit und für unser leben
und jetzt kämpfen wir auch für unser
überleben
und das ist die höchste motivation
aber wir kämpfen auch darum
gleichberechtigter partner in europa zu
sein
applaus für einen wunsch der bis zu
seiner möglichen erfüllung noch einen
langen weg gehen muss das sieht nicht
nur die kommissionspräsidentin so im
jetzt stellt von der leyen weitere
unterstützungen aussicht humanitäre
hilfe im umfang von 500 millionen euro
den krieg nennt sie einen moment der
wahrheit für europa
dies ist klar es ist ein zusammenprall
zwischen rechtsstaatlichkeit und dem
recht durch waffen zwischen demokratie
und autokratie zwischen eine aufregung
gestützten ordnung und nackter
aggression
wie wir heute auf das reagieren was
russland macht wird über die zukunft des
internationalen staaten systems
entscheiden in genf beim
un-menschenrechtsrat
diplomaten die russland demonstrativ den
rücken kehren als der russische
außenminister das vorgehen seines landes
in der ukraine rechtfertigt und
forderungen wie diese stellt die
westlichen länder müssen aufhören
militärische standorte auf dem
territorium der länder zu schaffen die
früher die sowjetunion bildeten und
nicht mitglieder der nato sind
einschließlich der nutzung der
infrastruktur dieser länder zur
durchführung militärischer aktivitäten
china wird heute zwar für weitere
friedensgespräche kann die position
russlands aber verstehen vor dem
hintergrund der fünf
aufeinanderfolgenden ost
erweiterungsrunden der nato sollten die
legitimen sicherheitsforderungen
russlands ernst genommen und angemessen
wahrgenommen
während us-außenminister blinken einen
ausschluss russlands aus dem
un-menschenrechtsrat anstößt und in
richtung china betont
ratsmitglieder sollten aufhören sich so
zu äußern als trügen alle seiten hier
die gleiche verantwortung für den und
provozierten angriff einer seite das ist
einfach falsch und verhindert die
verantwortung dahin zu geben wo sie
hingehört
in berlin zeichnet kanzler schulz ein
düsteres zukunftsszenario
noch eine ganz ganz dramatische zeit
werden ob die bilder die wir bisher
beklagen mussten und über die wir
bedrückt sind mit den vielen toten und
verletzten mit den zerstörten gebäuden
den zerstörten infrastrukturen die
werden nur ein anfang sein von dem was
wahrscheinlich noch kommt
internationale ächtung und sanktionen
gegen russland unterstützung der ukraine
durch solidarität humanitäre hilfe und
kriegsgerät bislang hat sich putin von
alldem nicht beeindrucken lassen
welche wirkung können die
internationalen sanktionen auf die
russischen oligarchen und das system
putin überhaupt haben und wer oder was
könnte ihn stoppen fragen die ich vorhin
einem angestellt habe der putin und sein
machtapparat sehr gut kennt und der seit
langer zeit zu seinen prominentesten
feinden zählt michael rogowski er war
einst der reichste mann russlands einer
jener oligarchen die das chaos nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion nutzten
und sich ehemalige staatsunternehmen
unter den nagel rissen
2003 viele frau doch copski damals chef
des ölkonzerns jukos bei punkten in
ungnade als der offenen kritik übte und
sich politisch engagiert aber auch kosky
wurde wegen steuerhinterziehung verklagt
und verbrachte zehn jahre in haft teilte
in einem sibirischen straflager
nach diplomatischen bemühungen der
deutschen regierung wurde er 2013
begnadigt und lebt heute im lotto
er nahm trotzdem
unterstützen
nur so
kann diese abende dieser letzten sechs
sieben abend da könnte man noch als gut
bezeichnen damit sind wir auch bei dem
thema über das wir sprechen wollen sie
sind es aus london zugeschaltet
da sind viele reiche russen haben sich
dort eingekauft in große immobilien
kaufen zum teil ganze fußballclubs sie
kennen diese oligarchen szene sie waren
ja früher selbst mal einer sie kennen
dieses system auch rund um putin ließ
ihre einschätzung angesichts der
wirtschaftssanktionen angesichts der
isolation international breitet sich der
unruhe in dieser szene aus in diesen
kreisen oder kalt das mehr oder weniger
an denen ab
bestimmt sind sie beunruhigt weil wir
sehen dass herrschaften wie michael
friedmann zb jetzt versuchen ihre
position zu ändern
herr abramowitsch meint erste zu einer
art vermittler zwischen der ukraine und
russland
aber es muss eine ganz klare frage
gestellt werden sind sie bereit das was
gerade passiert militär verbrechen zu
nennen
sind sie bereit zu sagen dass die
regierung russlands ein verbrecher ist
wenn ja dann sind wir auf der gleichen
seite kommt und wir werden irgendwie
überlegen was wir zu tun haben um das zu
stoppen durch begrüßt wurde falls nicht
gehen sie bitte zu ihrem putin zurück
studiosus
liniert weil
er hat dann überhaupt noch einfluss auf
putin sind das überhaupt die oligarchen
auf die erhört also man sieht im
fernsehen diese bilder wie herr putin an
einem ellenlangen gefühl 30 meter langen
tisch sitzt und zwei generäle am anderen
ende erscheint überhaupt niemanden auch
nur körperlich in seine nähe zu lassen
wer redet eigentlich noch mit diesem
mann über das was gerade in der welt
geschieht
problemen ja das geht
natürlich können das aber keine
einfachen worte sein es muss ihm jemand
sagen noch la die mir du bist am ende
und um das zu sagen braucht es den
militärischen widerstand den die ukraine
jetzt leisten
und es braucht die härtesten
finanziellen sanktionen
ich glaube dass die kontensperrungen
richtig sind
aber das reicht noch nicht damit die
russische gesellschaft aufwacht man muss
alles stoppen alles sperren egal welche
überweisung richtung russland und im
interesse russlands ich verstehe ja das
kann mein volk sehr hart treffen
vielleicht wird es alle russen auf mich
selbst treffen aber was können wir
machen um den krieg zu stoppen es ist
notwendig und in einem monat können wir
darüber nachdenken wie es weitergeht a
chinese zur
derweil das russische armee ukrainische
städte bombardiert und da immer massiver
eingreift aber die ukraine sie haben ja
selbst eben angesprochen die wehren sich
mit einer ungeheuren tapferkeit
das muss doch zu frustrationen im kreml
führen denn diese geschichte dass sein
bruder land und da wartet man auf
befreiung die ist ja so offenkundig
falsch
er ist natürlich empört und diese
empörung sehen wir daran dass er die
ganzen ukrainischen städte unter
beschuss genommen hat das ist ein
militär verbrechen die zweifellos was
kann der weiterhin machen das wissen wir
nicht ob er taktische atomare waffen
anwendet ob er beschließt dass nach der
ukraine ein nato land an die reihe kommt
weil die nato so schwach ist und sich
nicht einmischen kann
heute können wir das nicht wissen wir
wissen nur dass die ukraine kämpft für
ihre freiheit
für die sicherheit europas für die
freiheit des russischen volkes von
diesen machthabern und es liegt in
unserer hand die wir der ukraine bei
diesen kampf helfen können
am ende wird nur selbst diesen kampf
stoppen können wenn er gestoppt wird
kann er sich seiner eigenen leute
eigentlich noch so sicher sein oder
bedarf es einer blutigen revolution und
dass das überhaupt
realistisch
heutzutage fehlt es putin an
militärischen mitteln die ukraine unter
kontrolle zu bringen er schickt kräftig
in die ukraine die normalerweise gegen
den widerstand in russland benutzt
werden
und wenn es in russland zum widerstand
gegen die regierung kommt wird es ihnen
zwingen seine kräfte nach russland
zurück zu holen und es wird zu solchen
widerständen kommen wenn die blockaden
und die finanziellen sanktionen nicht
teilweise sondern komplett sein wird das
problem ja nutzer die
finanzmärkte
buddhistisch napoli
danach wirklichen widerständen russland
nicht aus weil das auch einfach
irrsinnig gefährlich ist also jeder
versteht wenn man angst hat auf die
straße zu gehen man weiß dass man da
sofort verhaftet wird sie haben ja
selbst erlebt was einem widerfährt wenn
man ein system putin zu harte kritik
denn man denke an der wahl also ich kann
jeden verstehen der angst hat
ja die menschen haben angst noch vor
einer woche hätte ich gesagt dass die
leute das recht haben sich zu fürchten
jetzt werden in der ukraine unsere
nachbarn getötet unsere freunde getötet
unsere verwandten sich zu fürchten das
heißt sie zu verraten und für mich ist
verrat das schlimmste wort deswegen
können keinerlei ängste diese
untätigkeit erklären wenn ihr angst habt
dann werdet ihr auf die straße gehen
wenn ihr keinen lohn mehr bekommt
das ist die schuld des volkes des
gesamten volkes diaz verantwortet weil
das volk erlaubte es dem machthaber
einen krieg anzuzetteln
der jetzt gerade in der ukraine die
leute tötet
sagt michael falgowski ich danke für das
gespräch
gesagt dass hinter wir haben wir
aufgezeichnet und dann schauen wir jetzt
nach moskau zu unserem korrespondenten
dort christiansen christian wir hatten
da gerade in dem gespräch das thema wie
viele russen sich überhaupt noch trauen
auf die straße zu gehen und gegen diesen
krieg zu protestieren dabei auch so viel
in kauf zu nehmen
ja schlicht gibt hier niemanden mehr der
diese massenproteste organisieren kann
der die massen wirklich hinter sich
vereinen kann und auf die straße bringen
der letzte der das geschafft hat der war
das war alexej nawalny und sein
schicksal kennen wie er sitzt im
straflager und jetzt gab es ja schon
versuche in mehreren städten es gab ja
auch demonstrationen immer wieder am
abend tausende festnahmen waren die
folge auf die menschen wartet jetzt noch
ein strafverfahren
und ich glaube viele wird gerne
demonstrieren gehen aber die angst ist
einfach sehr verbreitet und wenn man
dann heute meldungen hört dass es jetzt
sozusagen eine spezialeinheit gibt die
besonders die leute jetzt im visier hat
die solche proteste organisieren oder
irgendwelche aktionen geplant haben das
macht dann natürlich sorge und auch eine
andere meldung jetzt am abend machte
noch sorge dass die russischen behörden
jetzt vermehrt noch mal gegen die
wenigen verbliebenen medien hier
losgehen diesmal trifft es echo moskwy
ein sehr bekannter politischer
radiosender und tv doch sowieso schon
gebrandmarkt als ausländischer agent die
beiden wurden aufgefordert inhalte von
ihren webseiten zu entfernen die beiden
haben recht ausführlich und ausgewogen
so wie wir das in unserer
medienlandschaft erkennen über den krieg
berichtet und wurden im vorfeld schon
aufgefordert bestimmte worte waren ja
auch verboten in der berichterstattung
die beiden haben dass trotzdem gemacht
und jetzt bekommen sie die vollen
konsequenzen zu spüren am abend waren
die webseiten zumindest aus russland
schon nicht mehr erreichbar und echo
moskwy das ist wirklich eine institut
institution hier das ist nicht irgendein
radiosender sondern der es bei vielen
wirklich sehr beliebt und hat das
geschafft auch durch viele krisen zu
kommen der sender wurde in den 90ern
gegründet und hat viele auf und ab
erlebten hat aber immer geschafft
irgendwie zu überleben und hier noch
eine freie politische stimme zu bleiben
und diese stimme die wird jetzt morgen
früh oder ist schon am abend jetzt
verstummt aber morgen früh wird es
vielen wahrscheinlich erst auffallen
dass diese stimmen nicht mehr da ist und
das bedeutet was für russland allerdings
dankeschön für die informationen aus
moskau
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
protestiert aber nicht alle viele halten
sich auch aus china etwa die arabische
welt oder länder südamerikas da hört man
nicht viel das wurde heute auch bei der
vollversammlung der vereinten nationen
deutlich
johannes hano beobachtet diese sitzung
für uns zu der ja auch die deutsche
außenministerin gereist ist johannes
welche eindrücke hast du vom verlauf
dieser welt versammlung
also man berät er hier seit zwei tagen
über das was der sicherheitsrat nicht
geschafft zu verabschieden ich eine
resolution zum russischen einmarsch das
war am veto russlands gescheitert uns
liegt jetzt irgendwo vor der sieht vor
russland zu verurteilen den russischen
einmarsch zu verurteilen was dann wird
aufgefordert sofort aus der ukraine sich
zurückzuziehen und es wird auch scharf
verurteilt dass russland seine nuklear
streitmächte die einsatzbereitschaft
erhöht hat jetzt gibt es da verschiedene
lager zu dieser resolution ganz klar
russland und seine engsten verbündeten
nämlich syrien werden diese resolution
abnehmen und dann gibt es ein ganz
großes lager von denen die diese
resolution zustimmen werden aber auch
dass lage ist gespalten ergebnis länder
wie brasilien zum beispiel die die
russische position grundsätzlich
verstehen aber trotzdem zustimmt werden
weil man die karte der vereinten
nationen nicht außer kraft setzen will
dann gibt es das lager der and leute die
sich enthalten den ländern die sich
enthalten china und indien vorwiegend
china verspielt eine ganz merkwürdige
rolle einerseits sagt man möchte nicht
dass eskaliert weil auf der anderen
seite will man auch nicht verurteilen
und dann gibt es die ganz großen gruppe
der kleinen staaten die zwischen baum
und borke sind die nicht so genau wissen
wie sie sich entscheiden sollen weil sie
militärisch und ökonomisch abhängig sind
von china und von russland und darum
geht es jetzt deswegen ist die deutsche
aus ministerin gekommen um diese staaten
zu überzeugen und sie ist vor wenigen
minuten hier angekommen hat ja ein
statement abgegeben vielleicht können
wir da mal kurz rein
denn in einer situation wo es um krieg
und frieden geht muss man sich
entscheiden ob man auf der seite des
aggressors steht oder auf der seite von
familien von kindern die sich in u bahn
schächten vor bomben und raketen
angriffen verstecken in so einer
situation muss man sich entscheiden ob
man für das recht der stärkeren 1 steht
oder für das internationale recht in
einer frage von krieg und frieden kann
niemand neutral sein und deswegen bin
ich heute hier um dafür zu werben
positionen zu beziehen für die menschen
in der ukraine und für die charta der
vereinten nationen
dankeschön
aus dem restaurant wird hier in den
vereinten nationen darüber abgestimmt
über diese resolution man wird dann
sehen wie weit die weltgemeinschaft sich
hinter dieser resolution stellt
diplomaten sagen alles was mehr als 100
mitgliedstaaten ist die dieser
resolution zustimmen sei ein erfolg aber
100 von 193 groß und russland vielleicht
noch abziehen also 192 wird hier als
erfolg gesehen aber ob man das wirklich
als erfolg sehen kann bei dieser
unterschied 100 293 das weiß ich
wirklich nicht dankeschön johannes die
analyse von der vollversammlung in new
york
es ist ein krieg der bislang klassisch
geführt wird mit altbekannten waffen
panzer artillerie raketen beschuss aber
er findet dennoch in einem anderen
zeitalter stadt unter den augen der welt
beobachtet unter anderem von satelliten
oder nicht zuletzt unzähligen
handykameras und es wird bereits
gesammelt was man eines tages gegen
putin und seine kriegs generelle
vorbringen kann als belege für
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit
der chef-ermittler des internationalen
gerichtshofs hat jedenfalls schon
erklärt er werde ermittlungen aufnehmen
der gedanke dass putin eines tages auf
der anklagebank in den haag sitzt mag im
moment völlig realitätsfern erscheinen
aber hinzusehen was den menschen dort
angetan wird es sind alle welt zu tragen
ist das mindeste was wir tun können
putins lügen es nur militärische ziele
angegriffen sind längst widerlegt welche
eindrücke britische tv kollegen heute in
der ukraine gesammelt haben berichtet
diana zimmermann
der himmel über kiew sinnbild für die
lage im ganzen großen land das
krankenhaus der stadt hat auf krieg
umgeschaltet draußen familienautos ihr
ziel ist polen den ihre krebskranken
kinder können hier nicht mehr behandelt
werden
ganz ehrlich ich habe furchtbare angst
aber ich sehe keinen anderen weg wir
müssen es tun gehabt und
auch alina ist schwer krank sie schläft
nun in der badewanne
wegen der bomben sagt die dreijährige
auch diese familie müsste dringend aus
dem land denn die medikamente für palina
gehen langsam aus doch im heftig
umkämpften haag ihre mutter nicht was
das größere übel ist
es ist ein glücksspiel wir sitzen hier
und fragen uns werden sie unser haus
treffen oder nicht ich weiß nicht wie
wir rauskommen sollen alle sagen uns die
ganze zeit wir sollten nicht rausgehen
weil es so gefährlich ist ich weiß nicht
was ich tun soll ich hoffe es wird ein
sicherheitskorridor gebetet und jemand
holt uns raus
weiter südlich in neapel werden
zunehmend verwundete soldaten ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert
verwundeten kommen nun aus fast allen
richtungen vor allem aber aus dem osten
und dem süden aus den gegenden also wo
die besatzer von der krim kommen
wer nicht kämpfen kann oder will
versucht zu fliehen solange möglich
gleich sechs bahnhof lemberg nur frauen
und kinder schreien die polizisten die
grenze zu polen 80 kilometer entfernt
unendlich lang die letzten meter zum zug
unter den flüchtenden auch
austauschstudenten aus aller welt
ich bin hier nicht mehr sicher ich habe
alle meine persönlichen sachen zurück
gelassen mein studium bietet mit uns
für einige eine reise in die heimat für
die meisten abschied und eine ungewisse
zukunft
der it techniker dimitri hat gerade
seine diabetes kranke mutter zug zug
nach polen gebracht dann hat er kehrt
gemacht zurück in den krieg
klinische männer sind sehr sehr wütend
und wir werden jeden russischen soldaten
töten den wir in die hände bekommen
darauf könnt ihr euch verlassen louis
campbell der
bahnhofsplatz in lemberg dient nun als
flüchtlingscamp wo jeder etwas zu essen
bekommt kinder mit süßigkeiten abgelenkt
werden und bin ich seit vier tagen auf
einer parkbank lebt ohne feste bleibe
aber nie ohne make-up und wo ein
tapferer mann sein bestes tut die
stimmung zu heben musik gegen die angst
[Musik]
158 jetzt erstmal weiter mit weiteren
meldungen zu diesem krieg immer mehr
menschen fliehen aus der ukraine in die
nachbarländer nach angaben der vereinten
nationen stieg die zahl innerhalb von 24
stunden um
150.000 auf
677.000 und die hälfte von ihnen kamen
polen an 90.000 sind nach ungarn
geflohen auch die slowakei rumänien oder
moldau nahmen zehntausende auf die
vereinten nationen stellen sich darauf
ein bis zu vier millionen flüchtlinge
versorgen zu müssen
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie spenden über
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine iban de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
altkanzler schröder verliert laut
medienberichten alle vier mitarbeiter in
seinem bundestagsbüro darunter auch
seinen langjährigen redenschreiber und
büroleiter sie sollen demnach ihre
posten aus protest niedergelegt haben
denn obwohl es viel druck auch aus der
spd gibt distanzierte sich schröder
bislang nicht klar von putin und hat
auch seine arbeit als gas lobbyist für
russische staatsunternehmen nicht
beendet
der krieg in der ukraine betrifft auch
den kulturbetrieb der russische
chefdirigent der münchner philharmoniker
waleri gergiew ist entlassen worden in
einer mitteilung der stadt münchen hieß
es gergiew habe sich trotz aufforderung
nicht von russlands präsident putin und
dessen angriffskrieg distanziert auch
das festspielhaus baden baden die
elbphilharmonie in hamburg oder die
mailänder scala beendeten die
zusammenarbeit der 68 jährige gilt als
einer der berühmtesten dirigenten
unserer zeit
beziehungen würden abgebrochen auch
zwischen unternehmen deutsche firmen
werden ihre geschäfte mit russland nicht
mehr so weiterführen können wie sehr das
die deutsche wirtschaft treffen wird und
verändern wird das wird sich erst über
die zeit zeigen und über allem schwebt
die frage wie geht es mit der
energieversorgung weiter wie schnell
können erneuerbare energien erdgas und
öl ersetzen die deutschland zu großen
teilen aus russland bezieht die einen
sinnieren über längere laufzeiten für
atomkraftwerke
es spricht allerdings nicht viel dafür
dass das praktisch umgesetzt werden
könnte und die kohle rückt wieder
stärker ins blickfeld muss der geplante
kohleausstieg verzögert werden nicola
albrecht berichtet
zwischenbilanz wollten die drei
ministerpräsidenten aus brandenburg
sachsen und sachsen anhalt bei dieser
fachkonferenz ziehen den fortschritt in
sachen strukturwandel und energiewende
in ihren mitteldeutschen revieren
aufzeigen stattdessen auch heute in
cottbus die erkenntnis dass putins krieg
die welt in neue realitäten zwingt und
ihre region in ein dilemma stürzt das
vorziehen des kohle ausstiegs auf 20 30
wie im koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen mit
einem schlag vom tisch ich persönlich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir die
braunkohle deutlich länger brauchen
werden 2030 ein vorziehen des ausstiegs
aus der kohleverstromung auf zum
beispiel 2030 würde bedeuten dass wir
ersatzkraftwerke im gasbereich brauchen
und damit die abhängigkeit von
russischem erdgas noch erhöhen und
weniger abhängig von russlands energie
werden lautet in der energiepolitik das
aktuell oberste ziel doch weder
braunkohle als strategische reserve noch
gas als brückentechnologie werden
reichen das wissen sie hier die
erneuerbaren energien müssen her
beschleunigung das von allen akteuren
heute wohl am häufigsten gebrauchte wort
dass wir den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien deutlich beschleunigen es muss
viel viel schneller gehen wir werden in
dieser
in dieser phase in der wir sind müssen
wir alles beschleunigen den den
netzausbau den ausbau der erneuerbaren
auch die bereitschaft grünen wasserstoff
zu erzeugen grünen wasserstoff erzeugen
das wollen sie zum beispiel hier im
energiepark bad lauchstädt in sachsen
anhalt die voraussetzungen seien gut
nicht nur was die erzeugung und die
speicherkapazitäten betrifft weitere
standortvorteile sind dass wir hier die
vorhandene erdgasinfrastruktur haben die
wir um widmen können zu einer
wasserstoffinfrastruktur und dass man
auch nicht vergessen darf wir haben
bereits hier in der region die
zweitlängste wasserstoff pipeline liegen
bis die nutzung real wird dauert es
allerdings noch mehrere jahre auch in
brandenburg gibt es bereits viele
unternehmen im bereich der erneuerbaren
energien bei der windkraft setzen sie
zum beispiel nicht nur auf regionale
möglichkeiten sondern auch
internationale kooperationen fern von
russland das sind natürlich wesentlichen
die länder wo am besten die sonne
scheint und auch der wind besonders
stark weht ein ertrag als unternehmen
ist ja auch insbesondere aktiv im
bereich südafrika in cottbus ist man
sich angesichts der aktuellen lage einig
die kohle aus dem revier wird länger
bleiben und die erneuerbaren sollen
schneller kommen
und zu dem ganzen themenkomplex gibt es
nachher im heute-journal update noch ein
interview mit bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck der heute in washington ist mit
dem blick auf die wirtschaft in diesen
zeiten geht es jetzt auch bereits weiter
und auch da bleiben wir erst einmal bei
energie und energiepreisen denn sie
tragen deutlich bei zu hohen inflation
wie die neuen zahlen für februar zeigen
frank bethmann wie sie im einzelnen aus
öl gas und kohle bleiben mit abstand der
preistreiber nummer eins der krieg in
der ukraine verschärft die ohnehin schon
angespannte situation bei der inflation
nach einer ersten schätzung steigen die
preise hierzulande im februar um 5,1
prozent die für energie schnellen um
über 22 prozent nach oben aber auch
nahrungsmittel verteuerten sich deutlich
und es geht weiter heute klettert das
rohöl der nordseesorte brent auf ein
siebeneinhalb jahreshoch palladium
wichtig für katalysatoren hauptsächlich
aus russland kommen zog ebenfalls weiter
deutlich an das alles setzt sich auch
beim dax fort das aktienbarometer
rutscht unter 14.000 punkte verliert
über 500 zähler oder fast vier prozent
angespannte nerven auch am abend an der
wall street der dow jones index gibt
weiter nach heute knapp zwei prozent
vielen dank
zur krone situation in deutschland die
zahl der neuinfektionen ist im
wochenvergleich erneut zurückgegangen
binnen 24 stunden wurden dem
robert-koch-institut
122.000 111 neuinfektionen gemeldet das
sind 3791 weniger als vor einer woche
235 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei
im fall der in rheinland-pfalz
erschossenen polizisten gibt es neue
erkenntnisse zum tathergang die
staatsanwaltschaft kaiserslautern erhebt
den mordvorwurf jetzt nur noch gegen
einen der beiden festgenommenen
verdächtigen sie geht davon aus dass
allein der 38 jährige vor vier wochen
die polizeianwärterin und den polizisten
bei einer fahrzeugkontrolle bei kusel
erschossen hat der zweite verdächtige
bleibt aber wegen des vorwurfs der
wilderei und der strafvereitelung
ebenfalls in untersuchungshaft
im südosten australiens ist die zahl der
menschen die infolge heftiger
überschwemmungen ums leben gekommen sind
auf zehn gestiegen
viele bewohner des bundesstaates new
south wales müssen mit hubschraubern
gerettet werden die örtlichen behörden
riefen rund 300.000 menschen dazu auf
sich auf eine evakuierung vorzubereiten
auslöser für das extremwetter ist ein
sich nur langsam bewegen das
tiefdruckgebiet
meteorologen warnen vor neuen starken
regenfällen von denen auch sind
betroffen sein soll
das was von uns im heute journal an
einem weiteren tag der bitteren
nachrichten im programm geht es gleich
erstmal weiter mit der reportage reihe
37 grad um 0.15 gibt es dann also heute
schnell update mit gundula gause
immerhin was norden wieder auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch bei wird morgen
durch das hoch lina abgelöst ansonsten
ändert sich aber wenig ein paar
wolkenfelder ziehen auch richtung
nordosten ab und das tief über
frankreich schaufel ein paar
wolkenfelder in den südwesten heute
nacht ist es also im nordwesten stärker
bewölkt aber zwischen der ostseeküste
dem alpenrand ist es häufig auch
sternenklar rund dort wird es sehr kalt
da sinken die temperaturen auf minus 4
bis minus 11 grad milder bleibt das
unternehmen wolken im nordwesten mit 3
bis 0 grad am morgen steigern sich die
temperaturen besonders am alpenrand von
minus elf grad geht es da auf 8 grad
kühler ist es nur zum beispiel an der
donau oder an der ostsee mit sechs grad
deutlich milder wird am niederrhein mit
13 grad die dichteren wolken der nacht
ziehen ostwärts ab an der nordseeküste
zeigt sich häufig die sonne und hier im
südwesten da sehen sie diese hohen
schleierwolken von dem tief über
frankreich
ja und dann kann es bei ihnen auch
passieren dass es in der nase kribbelt
denn wie erlenpollen sind morgen in
einer sehr großen konzentration
unterwegs und außerdem gibt es auch noch
ziemlich viele haselpollen an dieser
pollenbelastung wird sich auch in den
nächsten tagen wenig ändern denn es
bleibt einfach sehr sonnig im nordosten
dagegen sind die wolkenfelder etwas
dichter und da bleibt es auch in den
nächsten tagen eher kühl am freitag
liegen die temperaturen bei zwei bis elf
am samstag bei drei bis elf grad guten
abend